let's roll 27 was it invite this guy has
beat me more than once and he will beat
me again if I'm not careful or even if I
am careful here we go my opponent is
typing my way they are typing watch out
your queen watch out for the Queen
that's true now you meet the stream you
quit talking to mute the stream okay
let's go Queens gambit accepted decline
declined it's the Queens gambit declined
Marshall defense is with their colony a
marshal defense okay I've seen this
before who here is a fan of the Marshall
defense this is not not so common in top
play why not anybody know gives up the
center for one thing two-to-one
advantage in the center hmm ok so this
is what what is this some some Marshall
gambit I'm usually one to just say you
know what no thanks to gambits but i
might say I might say thanks to this one
DC night see and Knight f3 pawn push I'm
gonna I'm gonna take it and say pretty
much show me this is this is the show me
variation so let's say black is
definitely have a space advantage I
think I just keep developing and see my
night I'm assuming is going to get
pinned and it's not getting pinned I was
mistaken now how to recapture pawn takes
that way if he comes under more fire I
could take her
can play my bishop here or just take
with my night so I don't have to worry
about a pin if I take with my night in
Bishop c5 I think I'll just take the
night the Queen's come off the board but
I'm still up about up upon wanna go with
that just just a sidestep visa this
potential pin with the bishop playing to
g4 and well i guess i could play more
aggressive as well since i don't have to
contend with the potential pin I don't
have to play something like Bishop e2
okay that is a check but I have some
decent options counter-attacking Bishop
Bishop d2 stuff or just bring my night
out um I don't see any issue with just
bringing the night out if attacked again
I think I'll play Bishop d2 as that move
is played what about Queen situ or here
now queen here yeah this is fun in situ
I was thinking for a second the bishop
could play to f5 not the case my night
is covering it if the night is removed I
could first take this night with check
important detail if the night is
captured I do not take with my queen
unless I want to lose with Bishop b4 so
Knight takes pawn takes I should
probably just have that imp remove but
I'll just hold off okay well let's see
Knight takes pawn takes I wouldn't have
anything else would I oh maybe maybe
there's Knight takes Knight I be on the
Queen so okay this I'm already feeling
as though this this can't be right this
can't be the correct continuation really
be going forward with this should be
five I was think about Knight takes
Knight but I think Bishop to b5 pins
that night and threatening to land a
fork yeah so wait a second now this is
okay
pinned night is pinned if Knight takes
Knight ok I don't I really don't have
any fear because I'm up I'm up upon I'll
have some trouble with getting my dark
square Bishop I'll but i don't i'm not
really behind in development and usually
if you're going to give up on that's one
one of the forms of compensation is just
to have a lead in development but i
think it's i think it's beyond that
point right now the black does not have
a leading development i will castle next
and as soon as i do that i'm actually
it's maybe rare to hear it but I'm
castling with tempo I'm getting out of
this pin and by getting out of the pin
I'm threatening efore okay I guess just
take this night with the bishop my first
thought is do with the bishop because if
i take with the night pond recaptures
its back to black having the move and in
an open position like this i think i
want to be more direct however maybe
there is not even a need to even take on
the square reserved is this not even
going anywhere he's not if he goes
somewhere i take here with check and the
King has pulled out so there's no need
in other words take on c6 instead now
threatening be for the night could take
here but again I take here with check
first and then I recapture and then this
King is very exposed so i'll be taking
here if black does not doing something
do something about that i guess i could
consider recapturing with my queen if
Knight takes Knight so since i'm off of
the one square and there is no Bishop b4
so let's say two minutes to figure
things out i am up i'm still up that pun
and my opponent is the side who is
actually a bit behind in development
castle that are not capturing okay we're
not having that I think I like taking
like this let's see what black does
taking with the pond yet ok so I'm going
to come back and I'm boxing this night
out and I guess finishing up i could go
b3 Bishop b2 or Bishop d2 just
threatening to move my knight somewhere
but actually what I do like best I don't
know maybe maybe I should do this yeah
i'm gonna go with this i was thinkin b3
Bishop b2 because I'm anticipating late
around rook the eight stuff and I would
much rather have a b3 a to structure but
I think this is fine the other thing is
I might want to rear out my knight to e
2 and then play my bishop to see three I
think my night being on f4 can be quite
disruptive or even d4 but as it stands
right now he's just kind of out of play
let's get him doing something he was
boxed out actually no he wasn't I could
have played here I was stupid the queen
is unprotected so I had that night move
ah let's try it again maybe I could get
here may I can still get here I would
have picked up the dark square Bishop
and then played here and I think it
would have been much much cleaner much
much cleaner I should have just gone
here right away I'm going about this d 5
squared I Lee indirect way see 3d 5 is
much better than e to F 4 D 5 keep that
in mind alright so I have checking
possibilities and okay he's being
protected half open file i'm still
threatening night to d5 my opponent is
back a minute one minute warning let's
are extremely i have i've a minute plus
30-second warning okay now i could do
this but i think i just want to take
this night out first what has my concern
anything i could just take here why not
do that i'm just going to take that in
this and then I still have checks i
still have this move available but not
anymore okay just right here i have
potential mate threats on g7 now and of
course
the Queen trade is happening Queen trade
is happening just back up night d5 place
that I wanted to go for quite some time
and just defend no time here double
rooks and cleanest approach is just to
keep trading and I'm actually picking up
another pond watch out for back rank
mates that's my last concern the last
concern is back rank mates no battery
mates my king I move my upon just so I
could get my king closer this is my past
pun still getting closer pushing my past
pond actually I should have played here
less was poor technique I should have
played to see for just to not even allow
this activity so this this was this was
a bad idea but what I could do the the
clean approach i believe to this is to
just play rook to rook to e3 and then
push my pawn even if i drop this guy so
now he's tied down and then he runs just
keep going and I'm not going to take
just two actually I could do that right
now there's also no time no time for
Team Black just watch out for steal me
then we'll stalemate one two three
already good game mr. colos good game
let's go back and flip this board all
right well Marshall gambit is that what
they were coming no not Marshall game
would excuse you it's the Marshall
defense not very common but I'm I
shouldn't have gotten that type of
advantage I'm not really used to seeing
c6 here well again I'm not used to
seeing the Marshall defense for one and
the other thing is just I'm not so sure
how am I trying to say how playable
really this gambit turns out i mean
let's see what i actually had some fear
I am still I am kind of seeing some
compensation for black but not how it
was eventually played like right here
after Knight f3 you capture and I think
capturing makes things easier for me
right now by releasing the tension
you'll know by my recapture I don't have
to worry about a pin for one thing and
you know i'm no longer guessing is
another you can maybe push forward I
don't I don't think pushing forward is
best but I think what is best is keeping
keeping the tension placing my knight in
the pin right away and I let me let me
retract something right here because I
just said I don't think pushing is maybe
a good idea but it is certainly
something I'm going to be thinking about
if your bishop is on g4 so Bishop g4 I'm
the one who's like who's guessing a
little bit here and after Bishop g4 I'd
break the pin which i think is going to
be my number one candidate move or one
of my cannon booze is going to be Bishop
to e2 then maybe you could maybe you
could take here and then take my bishop
and then regain a pond or something I
think this is going to be an improvement
Bishop to g4 keep this tension Bishop g4
first and then and then try this on this
other stuff maybe maybe you could still
be going with the Queen check or the
bishop check although I don't know how
much how much difficulty black poses are
white with these uh the Queen and the
bishop may be putting pressure on this
diagonal I think it's I don't I kind of
chalk up chalk it up as being more on
the not too difficult to defend side of
things it's it's not so I could defend
that with rep without much problem so
anyhow Bishop g4 i think is going to be
better and well if there isn't going to
be anything happening again against that
night this turns out to it turns out to
backfire really because I Perry the
threat all right yeah I Perry the threat
anthro a threat of my own and I'm
developing right my queen my queen is
out you really can't get at her just yet
with like might be for stuff I'm out
here developing pinning your night and
after I castle now there's another
threat so I think this also just kind of
backfires the idea to try and put
pressure on the night and and also more
long-term it sets you up to be
tactically vulnerable along this
diagonal right you're not you're not
really going to Castle Queen side so
let's just say hypothetically let's just
run with the the idea that you get the
pawn back at some point as a result of
this f4 move to secure this night's
position there's with such an open
position maybe in who knows how it's
going to work out but maybe there's a
way that I could be taking advantage of
this week in diagonal against black so
maybe maybe two reasons like if that was
your idea night 95 with f5 to follow a
reason to maybe a reason to maybe shy
away from that um but anyhow okay yeah
there's just not going to be any
compensation is like and I was saying
when we did get to this point I had 95
but I just moving too quick i guess was
one I was wanting to get to f4 but could
just jump into d5 get the darks for a
bishop and then
get on this doggone or something okay I
could game call us